yeah
has anyone else think this episode is so
bizarre
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
Mandalorian season three episode six as
always joined by my doll
and Josh is he okay
how are you John I am Interstellar sir
how are you I am Christopher Nolan how
are you Michael
uh is the baby okay the baby's okay okay
that's all that matters uh are you guys
excited
thank you so much for being here please
you know what to do use the force to
leave a like if you end up enjoying this
video as always full-length and watch
alongs re-sync up with your own copy for
the Mandalorian available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page thank
you to all her joined just for this show
alone but we also cover a bunch of stuff
exclusively over there as well and I
wanted to shout out everyone who did
purchase a shirt of the last daddy
here's an image of it real rejects
exclusive over at shopzeroedition.com in
24 hours it became our most sold shirt
ever I said that for this episode I'd be
wearing my shirt of it and um I'm here
to tell you guys
it's a scam no refunds
they were all nfts
t-shirts yeah there it is what went
wrong when I was trying to tell you
earlier what I wanted to do was get
Michael
um a shirt as well my gift was real
rejecture to him but it was like Star
Wars related and then I had the wrong
autofill information go in there now uh
whoever's living on my old apartment is
gonna get a nice surprise
subscribe to the channel now yeah like
what is this I love it I'm peeping it
um but thank you to all who bought one
anyway let's watch this episode
[Music]
thank you
oh that looks like a mon calamari ship
congratulations
[Laughter]
that's how star treky this is
hey didn't the other mandalorians
commandeer that see we've been
commissioned to track you down captain
sugath
fire The Blasters you see we were
already hired by a certain mon calamari
Viceroy you absconded with her son I
know it was for love
no I won't go
I won't go oh my we love each other
please
you have to go with them no I love you
please go
we knew fate was not on
who cares about fate I love you
oh man I will always love you
it's so nice more romance come with us
Prince
long ride home this is a nice little
callback to the Clone Wars can't imagine
wolves will be happy to see you I'll
land outside the fleet's perimeter
probably best if we go in on foot
they don't have any air detection you
will be guided on the assigned path
engaging automated guidance
what in the Disneyland is this
fascinating welcome to the experimental
prototype community of Tomorrow they've
taken control of the ship
I guess we're going for a ride
is it Disneyland ride
oh my God
is that a monorail track oh my God it's
literally Epcot I love it the sudden
urge to just leave here and go to
Florida
oh my God it's dark 2D2 and dark 3PO
Bizarro World version yeah welcome to
plazier 15. please proceed to your
hyperloop pod
all black ever we've got a hyperloop
bring us to the Bay closest to the
Mandalorian Fleet I'm
I'm super jazzed about all this your
presence has been requested by the
leadership please do not attempt to
leave the vehicle this is not a request
oh my God
oh man
oh it's just like the people mover at
Magic Kingdom
do you think we're gonna have to blast
our way out of here yeah find out look
at all those people
yeah there's a surprising concerning
lack of people certainly makes direct
democracy easier
foreign
more like a Doctor Who and Star Trek
episode that's exactly what it feels
like
[Music]
join us is that is that Jack Black it's
a party it sounds loud
I hope you like secretions
I'm thinking about sips
suffered great
as nobility we fell in love they did
nice
love is the theme of this episode
perhaps hold the baby
[Laughter]
same I'd like to speak to these
privateers that can be arranged
there's just one condition
see The View
deliveries right this way
finally a role worthy of Jack Black's
beard a drug problem completely
rehabilitated for peaceful purposes
exclusively we thought okay
I'm serious at first unexpected power
Cycles deleted task Stacks assault
assault our constables are ill-equipped
to confront battle droids battle droids
oh my God our constables aren't even
allowed to carry blasters but you
allowed us to be harmed exactly the
people have voted we are a pluralistic
society you are mandalorians weaponry
and armor are intrinsic to your culture
yes nice loophole you see where we're
going here
unlike my brethren outside
apologies if that is the impression I
gave what I intended
15 would formally recognize Mandalore as
a sovereign system and petition the new
Republic to recognize it as such
there is a benefit
what do you think
you had me at battle droids
we're all reprogrammed to serve the
community
what is this episode
what in the back of the Future Part Two
is this
Mr Fusion
you don't need all these clothes
oh no yes why not turn them all off
who's in charge of that
I am
let's finish this voted against any
Interruption enjoy Services they can't
live without it citizens are no longer
required to work they can spend their
days engaging Recreation the Arts okay
we shut down the droids our citizens
wouldn't know how to survive
dystopian Utopia give us the list
before that you'll have to go to the
lower level and speak to the yogurts oh
nuts coconuts
feels gotta have a cousin down there be
a cameo by Charlie Day down there
oh it's so cool to see prequel Eric
droids
are all played by Nick Nolte we were
sent on behalf of the duchess and
Captain Bombardier to help you with your
Droid problem
there's no Droid problem they're
programming them to be this way
you will answer our questions and help
us with our task I have spoken damn I
really do all know each other the droids
are not malfunctioning citizens have
been harmed
this is not the case this is not the way
here are the locations of the droids you
seek
thank you we are in your debt I have
spoken the droids are looking for
[Music]
ah this is wonderful what was that I've
spent time with hug nuts there's a
particular way to communicate with them
why not
I have one of my friends
this is awesome that is pretty cool any
of them most suspicious
they all do they all look suspicious
wow oh
this is the first time in Mandalore I've
ever seen Finn's flashback we're here on
behalf of the duchess to investigate the
Droid malfunctions
[Music]
uh I wouldn't do that if I were you why
why is that
I'm gonna caution I thought they were
just checked out
what are you doing and this shouldn't
phase them
oh no yes
are bad boom
that guy walking by re-certified huh you
should have left them alone
oh it's performing
wow he's fast run sunny
let's go
good use of the Boost
shove that guy
what a strange episode
whoa
I'm getting some
Terminator RoboCop Vibes right now
[Music]
a little lead a battle angel
but there's so many oh wow oh jeez
nice bow shot first
actually reminds me of Blade Runner when
Decker was hunting down that one woman
drug
chickens pockets for money
what's it say
the resistor whoa
and there's an address
divs ah yes the buddy cop Duo that we
didn't ask for
that I always wanted you kicking droids
is really not helpful you got back up
you did it your way now let me do it
mine okay this is my way this is the
address
this is the address
thank you
you're just such a strange episode
look at that juicy motor oil
I love the irony of this I don't think
they get many of our kind here
yeah Organics or sparse around here
that spark pad was found on a rogue
battle droid we give out lots of stuff
[Laughter]
full compliance with planetary
if you don't start answering questions
I'll yank your memory circuit and
dissect it back at the lab she just did
torture him
nobody leaves
you're gonna piss on this bar
you can reason with droids the behavior
is programmed all they do is reason
how's that going
oh bitter and Petty I want to help you
want me to pull your hearing sensors too
we don't want to be replaced we still
have a lot to contribute Organics
created us
it's the least we can do
you're a real hero
get a spin-off about this bartender
direct democracy right here
reprograms the Droids that drink here it
patches the programming as the commands
of the Mainframe change okay who's
programming the Mainframe it seems the
malfunctioning droids all imbibed from
the same batch of nabente
[Laughter]
what morgue
I love this so much it's so weird this
is such a strange episode
I'm here for it all the way
yes
sample please
I should have battled right before your
vitamin D is down the particles are
definitely present what are the chances
that they're still active
why don't they use that Droid more often
there you go that's a good question that
was the most effective Droid I've ever
seen the collateral damage Droid these
are the sub particles
midichlorians Yes actually nanodroids
yeah I know droids it's writing it's a
message rotate the perspective
it's moth Gideon's signature
it's a chain code you see what I can
find out follow the blockchain
they were originally manufactured by the
Techno Union oh chain title says it
didn't arrive on plazier through Droid
acquisitions
strange
how did it arrive evil these Droids were
ordered by an individual
is there a name
ahead of security Doc Brown damn it
commissioner Hellgate
no oh god oh I was so invested in here
security cameras for any potential
irregularities this is the most bizarre
episode
and the Nano droids
you them to disrupt and attack
you're coming with us
are those droids they are droids
everyone freeze
I'll Workforce back into battle droids
and unleash them upon the unsuspecting
citizens of plazier
literal kill switch
doing
there's no way out commissioner has
anyone else think this episode is so
bizarre this has escalated quite quickly
yes
you're a separatist separatist is a
pejorative term oh nicely done support
democracy
was a Visionary fascinating time by the
Jedi enforcers
I want to hear more about his thoughts
on counties
politics
oh that's so what a funny way let me get
that for you my lady
I am so dazzled by
whatever the hell we're watching
whatever drugs they did to conceive of
this episode
shrimps
afraid it is
despicable
[Laughter]
me
this planet is unrecognizable since he
arrived
I had a feeling you hated me is there no
room for a little bit of forgiveness in
a galaxy so vast
sorry to have disappointed you my lady
perhaps someday I can earned such
forgiveness I don't think so
as for now you must live in Exile on the
moon of paraquat
oh a paraquat
kumquat we must go to paraquat I also
give to you both our highest honor the
key to plazier
awesome let's have a parade
quite a dark saver but we can let that
go now and to this little one
I grant Knighthood
he's all kinds of things he's a Jedi
he's a Mandalorian he's a knight
go in peace Brave Travelers until I
passed meet again every season
I'm a lady
[Music]
it might just like sleep deprived no
this is this is a peculiar this is a
very strange based and weird I'm having
a blast but this is odd yes I'm just
gonna tie around to the stuff in the
beginning too they're going to follow
you
I'm not their leader anymore
Lex wolves is
then what's your play kill him
dual DIN and win I'll know when I get
there
oh no
Follow My Lead do what I do oh we're
still going huh okay
this episode doesn't feel real no it's
not real it's this is this is all a
fever dream you're asleep you've been in
the hospital for weeks wake up man this
feels like some weird comic book I'm not
command and
going quite fond of it then I challenge
you
know this
do you accept my challenge
not a if that's what you're asking
I do
this happens outside of Disney World all
the time by the way we shot this in a
park
nice
okay
yes oh man
dough
kill him
she has begaming looks all episode
watch out man wow
this is a well-produced fan film
laughs
what they were able to bring together
with just a few friends in a public park
oh wow that was cool nice
yield
you won't even take the top Super for me
oh dingarin took the Creed and chose to
walk the way
just as our ancestors did yeah he is
every bit the Mandalorian that they were
certainly as much as any of us ten times
the king with fossa was the ruler of
Mandalore must possess the dark saber
then she shall have it
give it to her that's right that's a
curse no just do it curses aren't real
buy it from me while exploring Mandalore
I was captured and this blade was taken
from me the technicality she defeated
the enemy that defeated me
yes that is literally a technicality and
I'm here for it this is the loophole
[Laughter]
belong to her I've been hoping Bo did
not notice this
it would
Oh Captain My Captain
I returned this blade
to its rightful owner nice
to the rebels pose
okay okay hello
[Music]
hold it up
fried rice
wow that was this episode huh Johnny
favs yeah no this says John Favre
original
I mean he craps out these scripts
and he wrote all the Mandalorian he
wrote all of them
let's get him out which details did I
put in which show again oh crap
oh God
that was that was a lot that was
I mean it was
it was fun I had a blast yeah that was
not
jables I wouldn't say that was her best
work
that straight up palazzos and Star Wars
Christopher Lloyd yeah this is a fat
stack of notable guests and then
probably a bunch of other like character
and voice actors to boot
I felt like this was fake it was super
fake the
not really happened it didn't it didn't
feel fake to me but it did feel like I
peered into an alternate universe where
this was the sixth episode of the third
season Mandalorian and the Multiverse of
Madness sure man what happened here
this season has been eight different
shows
smushed into one this was and I haven't
hated it
but man oh man this episode in
particular though was something this was
mcclunky all right
clunky
we were border we got something else
there
oh let's talk about it all right John
you seem to be the most positive
take it away uh yeah I had a blast I
will not try and cover up the idea that
this does feel like a kind of a an
incongruous note I'm I'm a little torn I
mean like you know part of this journey
over the entire course the show has been
a nomadic one has been sort of bopping
between different things but yes as
we've crested into season three it
certainly feels like things are
struggling to decide whether they want
to be really serial or really episodic
and uh that stuff aside I don't know I I
was very Charmed by the Oddball uh
quality of this uh I can't pretend that
it's strangeness of tone does not uh you
know undercut some tension or or you
know some of the just I don't know
quality of the overarching thing that's
happening or trying to happen but I
don't know that I had a blast with this
I just I can't really
just say otherwise uh yeah I don't know
I like this whole investigating the
droids who are you know going haywire
and Jack Black and lizzo doing their you
know
Royal folk and uh and then you know
Christopher uh uh Lloyd looking like
he's about to fall over and die
or else
uh yeah I don't know I was very Charmed
despite uh what this is in totality but
yeah
that's that's my that's my two cents
Michael I know you want to get in there
buddy Shrek in space tell me that wasn't
do lock like do lock is a perfect place
it is and so is wherever the hell we
just were for the past yeah 40 something
minutes uh no I mean it was it was super
weird uh uh I mean listen I'd be lying
if I said I didn't love every single
millisecond of the chaos uh but from
like uh like as a producer as somebody
who's had to like write and and like
bring to life a feature film
um there has been like a blatant
disregard for uh I think a comprehensive
cohesive narrative uh and I think you're
able to get away with that to an extent
um I've kind of reached the point and
maybe this is a hot take and I think
this is like my first negative hot take
uh it's time it's time oh here comes I
could feel the people cracking the
knuckles getting ready to comment I feel
like Marvel struggled from a similar
Affliction where
all of a sudden it became like a oh
we're just gonna throw in these cameos
to the degree where they kind of lose
their their nuance and and any fun that
there is to them like I I like a good
little Cameo I think it's great when
it's like oh turns out that Stormtrooper
was James Bond like that's pretty neat I
think like I could have handled Jack
Black I could have handled lizzo I could
have handled Christopher Lloyd I
couldn't handle all three of them in
this same episode to the point where it
took me out of the narrative and and you
know Greg you had a comment earlier like
yeah it kind of did feel like a fan film
and I think a lot of this season uh has
been that and you know part of me is
like well that's what we've been asking
for right like we we want something
that's made by the fans for the fans
um but I feel like there there does come
a point where it starts to do a little
bit of Injustice to the story and I felt
like they had some really interesting
beats in this episode that I would have
loved to just like sink our teeth into I
mean I think there was something really
interesting about
you know playing with this idea of like
oh the Empire treated former separatist
planets in like a really awful way and
there's implications to that
um but instead of like that we got
whatever this really interesting silly
fun thing was
um you know I mean and there's a lot of
pieces that like who knows maybe they'll
have a payoff like the opening with with
the the the mon cow love affair like
what was going where is that could like
you know it's just to recontextualize
ax's gang as as a more no like hard line
group now under his watch it's just
breaking up I don't think that romance
is ever coming back no well but like in
the Star Wars fan of me is like well
moncal is like where you could build an
incredible Fleet which could come in
handy for the Mandalorian sweater and so
but like I I just don't know where we're
going and we're now at the point like an
episode like this if you're gonna get
this off the rails do it really really
early on I feel like we're way too late
in the game to be going on this sort of
misadventure but that being said Greg
your opinion is the one that really
matters here yeah sure
uh as you are holding the the baby conch
I have said many times that Mandalorian
is my most favorite thing Star Wars has
done
um did I have fun I know what I hate did
I have fun watching this sure did I have
fun for the reasons they intended though
that
is the ultimate question this is like
it felt like a b movie it felt like a
fan film none of it when I say it
doesn't feel real I'm like I don't it's
not that I don't feel like we're
stepping into a fever dream it feels
like all this feel Everything feels fake
to me none of it feels truly it's the
question it is
like there's something about this that
just doesn't feel lived in it and I I
kind of experienced that a little bit
more with some of these episodes of
season three so far and this took like
forever to come out so I thought this
wouldn't be an issue yeah but there is
something especially with unless it
takes place in like some dark ass place
there there's something with its tone
and it's pacing
and it's lighting where none of it a lot
of the time it just doesn't feel real
anymore and I would never say that about
season one and two it was the exact
opposite about season one and two like
look how I feel like I'm I get to live
in this world again and then here
everything just feels artificial to me
and this episode in particular yeah I
had fun because I was laughing at the
episode this I was laughing at it I
don't feel like
like the the way they treat you could
have Bill Burr in here and it's it's
really believable yeah he's great as
Mayfield He's phenomenal as Mayfield
Jack Black was like this is a sketch now
and there is seriously no tension no
Stakes we are zipping across everywhere
in this random City and and then we try
to tie it back in into what feels like
the equivalent of kids who love making a
fan film in the park
we were all once one of those kids we're
live in Los Angeles there's all of us
here go to the park tomorrow you'll see
them
I don't know what happened here and
Bryce Dallas Howard made this episode
and I don't think it's a Bryce Dallas
Howard problem it's something going on
with the mouse house I I I and I I'm
gonna chime in there because I've I've
got a hunch uh I think that there
finally really was a genuine master plan
that was being put into action by
Favreau and felony and I think a big
part of that was going to be several of
these spin-off shows the ranch is the
new Republic and there's just been
episodes that are like so clearly what
that show was supposed to be I mean I
would be surprised if if they genuinely
wrote grogu out as they intended and
then were told you know
had bad episodes because when they were
boring yeah this wasn't boring no this
was
you really don't have a thought oh I
wasn't cueing body language to be like
let me jump in here
the only thought lingering on my mind
right now is just that like everything
you did in this episode I think or at
least the multiple things they tried to
do in this episode could easily have
each filled like you could have had the
Droid problem with lizzo and Jack
Blackbeard's whole own thing you could
have the droids and what they're going
through as a community of sentient
beings and that be its own thing and
then you could have the re uh
Distributing of the dark saber earning
back the respect of the fleet all that
could have been its own story in episode
that just shouldn't have been an
afterthought this was so ridiculous that
was uh that is I don't mind the choice
of of them finally finding a way around
a duel but in this episode that is like
a legitimate gripe yeah we're just
taking care of this in like a three
minute chat yeah
after that like look at this terrifying
conversation between the armorer and bow
and this like really spooky like think
about where we left the last episode the
dark tone of of blue discovering the
empty Imperial shuttle yeah then to
whatever this was you know and I think
and and here's the critique like I
totally agree with your note about the
it being lived in uh or or not being
lived in in this case and that was
something that I think people really
fell in love with Star Wars because it
was so textured because it was this
retro futuristic like really fun uh it
made it so it wasn't all shiny and
glossy and to George Lucas's credit when
he did the prequels I still think he
managed to achieve a sense of oh this is
lived in but it's still new and shiny
and it can be ornate whatever this is
now is neither like the prequel or the
original in in terms of what it provides
not even the Disney sequels no it's
literally quantumania I mean like
the the and I love Guardians I'm saying
this feels like a I think we're I think
you and I at least are like this feels
like there's a production problem that
happened with this season yeah so I
could see that sure yeah well because
they got a lot of the same returning
directors and and filoni is I mean he's
credited as writing and I know he's
involved but uh but I know he's also
spearheading the Ahsoka show there's
there's but there's a magic when you put
those two together and like favro and it
was like well they balance each other
out in such an important way because I
think
you know both of them are such talented
creatives but like I mean I think
speaking you know with my producer
writer hat on for a minute like there's
certain projects that like sure I could
try to do it by myself but if I do it
without like my proper creative Partners
it's gonna be off the roads and you know
I think the the problem
um and this is the same issue that
Marvel has in my opinion is you get to a
point where like yeah you can only like
stretch out Kevin foggy like Gumby for
so long
before he rips into pieces uh and it's
it's not a critique of of the creatives
as as much as it is you know I mean they
have enormous pressure on them right now
as as the flagship series for Disney
plus to deliver and I think in the
process uh they've been set up to fail
it doesn't even feel like it's about
denjarn anymore well and and I could be
fine I could be fine with that choice I
think the problem is it doesn't know
what it wants it does yeah it doesn't
replace it with something more
interesting and focused yeah and listen
I love Beau I love the Clone Wars ARC I
love all that stuff I cannot like
believe that the build-up of Bo winning
back her Mandalorian compatriots and
getting the dark saber is going to be
written off in the last five minutes
yeah that's
it's not fair it's it's not fair and
like the and honestly kudos to those in
the comments section because everybody
called out the technicality but like no
offense to our comment section but one
would hope that the writers that are
paid lots of lots of lots of money to
think something out would maybe go a
little bit deeper than than what we all
came to the conclusion of uh immediately
thereafter like did didn't intentionally
wait till they were in front of people
and now I'll do this technicality speech
and let people get sick of this and then
I'll make my move yeah yeah and and you
you set up a character that we had like
what five minutes with to to I know just
what is happening with this show
listen they've how many episodes do we
have left
uh two oh no yeah I've never been
worried for this show but yeah when you
got to hear when this is be such a
pivotal episode and they turned this in
and Bryce Dallas Howard directed it I'm
like something else is going wrong here
and because I know I just know for a
fact I know a lot of the people who
already mattered has probably already
clicked off I know there's gonna be
people who are like it feels like a
Clone Wars episode
and I say this is somebody that's
watched it three times through
there's still Arts there are still rules
that they follow I think this is like if
you took one episode out of like four
different Clone Wars arcs and then just
damaged them right there they just
jammed it into one which which like
frankly what this felt like in my mind
was like season one or two have flown
yes yeah like there's there's no excuse
for the third season of a show of this
magnitude and this much talent you know
I'm I'm I'm really I'm gonna be
cautiously optimistic I think that we
have to remember this season of
Mandalorian is the last of the jpeg
debacle uh in terms of The reigns of
Disney being handed back over here it's
like two years
was this affected by covet I mean had to
be I mean everything's been affected by
covet but maybe that's what they're
always going out of their way of being
like we already wrote season four
it's all planned out
jpeg though I think I mean this is like
the epitome of why they they gave him
the boot is for this kind of
mismanagement but I mean honestly and I
hate to like beat the drum on this and
like listen I I'm I'm forever
appreciative to Kathleen Kennedy for her
contribution to film and TV God knows
she played an important role in all the
films that I loved growing up
um but I think it's it's genuinely time
to like if this is going to be a
marvel-esque property that we take
seriously the flagship show cannot do
what they did this episode yeah um and
you know I I think there's there's so
many
I mean the whole just like play this out
in your head for a sec
this entire series its entire purpose
thus far has been to try to explain the
lack of cohesive storytelling that went
into the sequel Trilogy like every
single action with the grogu and it
turned to cloning and all these
different connective threads are trying
to make up for the lack of cohesion that
that landed them into this debacle in
the first place and what I'm seeing is
no lessons have been learned I really
that's why I like the third episode
because it's like these are choices and
plots and fetch quests that are being
driven by emotional choices and a good
narrative even even people were like oh
I'm a fan of that third episode of
Pershing I'm like I think this
exceptionally better than what this one
is by far I love the second episode and
out of all these episodes I'm like I
like the others and I I but like the
what the faults that I would find with
the others it all came to like a massive
culmination in this one and when you
have eight episodes like okay I can't
just settle for like B movie fun after a
while like I had fun watching it but I
was certainly laughing at it and not and
not and it didn't feel like it was
intentionally supposed to laugh with it
sorry John we have been talking so much
oh it's a weird episode
what's more to really say I mean I just
find that very entertaining but like I
can't really disagree with almost
anything you guys have brought up here
and I think that yeah if the sheer
amount of guest stars too it's like I
think you could have made Jack Black and
lizzo work uh if we had a little bit
more time with that and a little better
ways to Tamper the humor there and then
you have Christopher Lloyd who's like
you know he's not just gonna be selling
Cameo and it's probably not going to be
these two lovebirds over here so like
yeah I don't know yeah I'm not even I've
never complained about this show
cinematography but I've noticed like
lately it's just everything's so
freaking bright
and and it just feels like actors in
front of a green screen now or the
volume it just looks like actors in
front of a volume and like the sets
generally don't truly feel like someone
they went to the city it did it reminded
me a lot of uh uh uh the cannabite
Cantina uh sequence and sure SQL trailer
it's just very like what this isn't
it's Star Wars it didn't and Vogue play
was this weird Dynamics to me it was a
little weird dynamic their chemistry
needed something else then it needed
some more time together or or something
in a more serious tone because it's just
a weird I can I'm completely there with
you and I love both of them I mean I
think I love them both individually yeah
exactly
um no I mean frankly the the only stuff
that's like really had like
dramatic tone and like really been I
think down to earth uh I've really
enjoyed the armor sequences sure which
is crazy because not a character that
should have that much emotional weight
but like I love the tension that I feel
there and
um I don't know I we we know what
they're capable of and I think that's
what's disappointing uh and listen this
would have made a great holiday special
it felt like that well and that I mean
too I feel like we didn't really have
any time to at least in other episodes
or other Star Wars media where they have
introduced like oh hey we're having a
feast or something or you're on a new
world granted I mean you're living in
the problem of their society being so
Droid based and all that stuff
recommissioned blah blah but yeah it's
like when you join them at this banquet
thing maybe I don't know unpack a little
bit of what the significance of this is
or what cultural you know element it is
serving in one way or another rather
than just yes a bright garish excuse to
have a bunch of recognizable Star Wars
species he's in one room together or
something like that
yeah
um this is sad it's like yeah it's like
it's a sci-fi movie hodgepodge at a
certain point yeah I mean they were like
like we said earlier it was like Star
Trek Star Trek Vibes but like like the
knock right episodes of Next Generation
yeah like like I got a lot of that uh
and there's certainly no shortage of
like doctor it was just weird it was it
was like a low budget
I yeah it felt like what happened to
your money yeah why does the front door
looks so much better that they burned it
all on mandolin like that I mean that's
cinematography in in the the mind I know
Mandalore that was where it went they're
like they've used too much of the jet
packs it's it adds up Chris yeah it's
like I feel like now the Mandalorian is
becoming a show to set up other people
and other shows which is not
again lessons not learned it just feels
like din jar and it's but especially
kuroku but it's hard and Croaker are
just walking through the show for like
other people's yeah they literally just
happened to be there which has always
happened but yeah it doesn't have that
Kung Fu Essence no it doesn't have that
Mad Max Essence yeah and even I mean
what a lost opportunity with with bow
and den to create some tension between
would-be Ally like there was a room for
really interesting character development
and growth for for Bo to put her people
above her own ambition and instead she
just got handed everything she could
have ever wanted
um oh God that's so that's that is so
silly to me this was so silly well
there's
just enough episodes left to either
break our hearts or change our minds I'm
genuinely concerned the next two will be
two hours a piece that's how they'll
make up
honestly I'd be cool if they if they
said we're gonna pause We're not gonna
put out the next two episodes and we're
gonna take the next two to three years
to get our stuff together I will
continue to pay for my Disney Plus
subscription in the meantime like ah God
anyway guys oh man what did you think I
know it was fun but be honest with
yourself what do you think I like the
reject Nation a lot because we generally
even if we're negative we tend to
attract the ones who are optimistic and
positive and I love that about the
reject Nation yeah I do too it's
generally tends to be the top comments
of like I had fun and I I support that
and I encourage them and that's what
that's what TV and Star Wars is at the
end of the day I guess
I guess my Hope was that the bar might
be raised just a little tiny bit yep all
right guys well thanks for being here
tell us your thoughts you excited for
thrawn to show up in a hilarious episode
of the Mandalorian
[Laughter]
all right let's send this with a patreon
Lance door listen if anybody could fix
this it's you buddy you're already out
there helping the people of Canada stay
safe from all sorts of natural disasters
come in and fix the disaster that has
become lucasfilm I'm sure that you with
your No Nonsense and your holistic
approach could probably come up with
some kind of a you know interesting hook
for the writers to follow and then from
there you will be the savior of the new
Republic of all of the people of the
Star Wars Galaxy you could unite them
all under one umbrella of good
storytelling Lance and if not I mean I
think if you just like you know took off
your shirt put on a Mandalorian helmet
you know and oil down your chest a
little bit I mean you can make everybody
forget that any of this ever happened
I'd buy that calendar yeah and then get
Bryce Dallas Howard to shoot the
pictures of the calendar so they'll look
as good as they possibly can and then
both her directing career which has been
polished as of this episode will be will
be mended you know and then you will
rise as the hero we always truly deserve
to lead us into a new age so stay safe
out there Lance because you got a lot of
responsibility riding on your shoulders
I have spoken this is the way maintain
your pledge we love you buddy love you